[Music]
yeah I was Sean
I worked giftee I'll be talking about 80
testing framework we built for our
search engine last year using sparking
Scala started a little bit about me I'm
the search engineering lead activity a
little bit about my background I've
always been into kind of quantitative
problems and mathy stuff the bottle and
then I'm kind of meandered around my
study con the physics you know an
analyst and then it's a data science
work in and out or search focused
engineering I can follow me on Twitter
and s wonders for acquittals less than
too quickly
a little background Izzie the largest
gif search engine out there we love
gifts a company love s to be like that
throw them in our presentation of a lot
of gifts in this presentation just some
background numbers about three or four
hundred million people so you get from
us every day
we served three to five billion gifts
per day all around the world we service
around 400 million searches per day our
API Carver's piss all over the internet
Facebook Instagram snapchat Twitter
tender events especially a lot of funny
internal stories of don't we do employee
reactions shoot sometimes and sometimes
I've given it up in weird places on
tinder there's a funny story from that
it operated apps for iOS Android we have
if you were oh that's an AR f don't last
reducing the new Apple AR kid why should
you care about this topic what's the
real purpose behind it so for background
we build maybe testing framework for our
search engine last year terms like the
company it's fairly small team about 20
engineers certain teams specifically the
built this is poor engineer
and beneath it also on top of that
frequently ship a lot of product and
algorithm improvement to the team so we
need to invest very strategically and
larger in structure projects we don't
want to be working with low operational
overhead beyond the bandwidth for the
lot of those problems so this is kind of
fun most little lessons we had having to
build this within those constraints like
building something is still very
scalable and reliable but still can be
done with kind of fast iterative
development cycles having a really
minimal operational overhead we do run
the most current destruction on AWS
which makes some of that easier but also
as a team like there's very close to the
product and can't be it's been in a lot
of time on infrastructure and that's
pure data engineering all day so I'm
gonna start with a little architecture
overview and I'll get into kind of some
of the factors that led to you know
being able to do this successfully in
the project so the high-level
architecture a little of this is cut off
here on the printout left it's just like
this is in the context of our website
there's user browser running rack jas
it's a back in django web app we encased
her
get the API which talks to a search
micro service which kind of front
elasticsearch and power search results
we also have this other thing on the top
right of the ping back micro service
which is service specifically for
collecting behavioral events would be
used to measure a lot of like you know
impressions and clicks and all this
stuff signals of beat it measuring
performance maybe testing and that
service actually validates the quality
of events that come in against the
protobuf schema everything has to kind
of fit a certain standard then we have
these two kind of sources of data we
have this back-end context and they
guide I think in terms of what was
searched all the development results
that came back the VIP corresponding to
the partner integration mister came from
of them in these hundred events like
impressions and clicks and hovers and
everything you've been doing with an
actual result grid that they get both
those get logged into his firehose and
then they end up being as three buckets
and then you use a you are a lot of
smart orchestrate a lot of these
analytics don't we have something is
called the search essence job kind of
takes these two sources of these Kinesis
dreams
Ivan joins them together in session eyes
to them so you have the backend context
of the request and then all the
front-end events we kind of a session of
what users did for a research what time
of day like did they click that they not
been they convert and this search has a
job he's into a lot of other analytics
and data scientists and look in this a
lot have both ideas for how to improve
the user experience with search
algorithms we the so news Park job that
beats that data already test
you know and kind of read all the data
the behavioral stuff that happened at a
session and then past you to point to
different groups and kind of measure
performance for different uh certain
algorithm changes those results in s3
and then we can eat all those into
redshift kind of our final data
warehouse and use a looker kind of
create a lot of user dashboards over
that
I'll show you example of that here it's
a little background here there's an AP
test beer in last pump Department known
award but this was evaluating using our
Google code climate and it's like an
automatic automated service or computer
vision image detention so it's kind of a
value in that is a source of automated
tags for our gift and you can kind of
see in these dashboards on the left you
have all user groups you know you have
the experimental group and might blue
and the control group in purple and they
also split it out my desktop and mobile
the middle on the right and then you can
see if this test from the very beginning
there was a pretty good differential and
click the rich or the experimental group
which is what we like the scene witness
the change we introduced have a you know
measurable positive effect you kind of
see throughout the duration of the test
both mobile and desktop this was a
sustained
you know we're happy to see we also kind
of measured the statistical significance
with this we kind of think the mation
approach to a/b testing rather than the
preconditions approach they kind of
gives us a little more intuitive feel
for the probability that the scenario
we're seeing is you know
winner and you know the very beginning
it was a pretty pretty highest because
because he was low on the first day it
was wasn't all the way there was like
maybe 95 percent but as we got more data
and it came handed slowly compared to
most 99.99% of statistical significance
which is great to see
so given building this thing we were
able to build this in the course of
about two months and started running and
on live test would be to use it for a
lot of feature developing our search
algorithms and has been have a pretty
effective thing but I'd like to kind of
talk about some of the factors that
played in some of the success some of
them being technical choices some of the
beam were general principles and beliefs
we kind of call it as an engineering
organization first thing is kind of the
principle just standing on the shoulders
of giants and it's been so much work
great work it comes from the tech
community and leveraging a lot of that
the open source Danny Pacific evolved
has evolved tremendously don't remember
like this five years ago before smart
really took off like Freddie
pig and I'd never been having the right
bra job of mappers and reducers to kind
of just analyze some simple data the
nowadays gets so much amazing time for
freedom it'll be kind of take them for
granted sometimes like it's really
evolved so bad it's kind of moment that
our fingertips to use another thing is
just kind of go with the flow you don't
try not to reinvent the wheel there's a
lot of great momentum in different
communities out there and I'm just
playing by those rules and using that
act makes like pretty good reliable
production systems so he's one of the
SPARC works for data engineering and
data science
really kind of powerful that we love
he's parking lot you're not familiar
that I'm sure most of you are but it's
not a columnar highly optimized program
for analytics it's also kind of kind of
like the fact of a format for spark so
you said that spark is really easy and
you know it's a compatible with a lot of
other data tools as well we all see the
protobufs or upstream was like a kind of
an interface definition language between
services and provides a collectible
schema but it's a nice structure and
compile-time
guarantees another thing is of users
kind of on every book principle so the
whole idea my dad is gonna having like
one giant monolithic code repository it
sounds kind of like a terrible idea at
first but once he started there's a lot
of advantages to it we use a tool called
pants that's so these kind of built it
was specifically designed for many
anything wanna repose so what gives us
the ability every fine grain dependency
management and kind of pretty fast
builds for specific services and tools
provide multi-language support for the
Scala Java Python C++ go JavaScript one
example out there that Basile clock
enough mother was a lot of the advantage
of this is we kind of have shared code
in the same repository between my drugs
being services like our search service
and then also our downstream analytics
spark jobs you don't have to worry so
much about having different repositories
and incrementing the version it's a
library and driving that version across
all be the places that also use that
library
it's all in one place that's one of the
big selling points before you go it's a
pencil bowl in a lot of place that have
adopted the Google and Facebook and so
here's an example of kind of one of
these advantages like in our basically
of this shared library where we can
define it's called a user per group
pretty tough so there's kind of two
different instances of this integration
there's a control group work there's no
in changed users and then the experiment
group where we'd rolled out the
percentage of users some kind of change
so then there's kind of user group be
known in the use and two different
places in this case we can use in our
actual spark job or doing the
attribution or maybe testing performance
between filter our actual search
sessions based on the user ID and the
control group in the experiment or the
calculate performance metrics across
those two groups for our analysis
evaluation but then also in our actual
live search service when user requests
come in in real time we can give them
that that user ID that serves we can
hash them into that group you know be
control or the experiment experience and
the their search results another thing
we really like is having type safety you
Scala a lot of things in our production
services and also in all our spark
analytics code haven't host compile time
guarantees saves us a lot of cases and
especially the code base grows I mean
for me
Onis things that depend on the same
stuffs just having that you know as
compile time errors bubble up rather
than run time errors makes things a lot
easier
it also allows us to not to spend as
much time unit testing we're still
people need per se you to test them you
know you're right plenty of them but you
don't have that you have to unit test
every possible little we also used the
data set you can spark plug it's kind of
the best of all worlds no it's time safe
that's very functional and also very
performance super layer that kind of
evolution of data sets of its partners
person armies and data frames about
being a sense of the latest thing and I
think two years ago in an RV days and
face one functional there type safe but
they were kind of there's a lot of DPM
object overhead on a DM objects and it
distributed data that then they kind of
came out with this data frame thing in
Phase two there's this part but and ISM
had a lot of steeple and functionalities
then the kind of overall double engine
folks for more performance benefits
catalyst query optimizer that's really
smart highly performant this probably
tungsten provides a lot of performance
moves to be a things like code
generation and more explicit memory
management get it closer to bare metal
performance on the JVM
but the downside here is it's not very
types a if you get along your on type
errors and it kind of takes cast things
here in there it's just you don't get
those same functional about guarantees
you got with
our data set and now phase 3 we have
data sets
kind of like our bees on the data frame
engines you give them that functional
Scala type safety of our duties but that
the engine and the performance of the
data frames and different actually a
subset of data sets now it's the data
set of my bro just one note to make the
data set you guys stop for a picture are
a little annoying headache things like a
lot of times we're using more custom
data type tipton let's apply these kinds
of implicit encoders at the surprise
motor we have for our store sentient
objects which it works it's fine but
perfect another principle we like to
follow not is having three flexible
students our gaze on spectra came back
from these momenta as they come from web
browser or mobile clients it's make it
very flexible so Ryan can obviously
patch that they will understand curve in
we also like there's some upstream data
validation and arcing back servers we
have a wrote above spent they think it's
validated against a lot of optional
fields are still flexible and then using
protocol [ __ ] screamed at Parque
downstream of both formats and all are
flexible for changes when we need to
know and in fields or deprecated old
fields the final principle that made
this kind of a successful project
Russell just try to keep things as
simple and constrained as possible when
imperfection is only the old saying
perfect is enemy of good
so the things we did that really keep
simple for example for our AP test
analytics we went with a batch format
rather than the screaming experiment but
nice but for any testing is bad form
actually lends itself for the both as
you want to you don't want that instinct
to constantly be watching the
performance of tests and turning it off
when you meet certain statistical
thresholds it really should just have a
set amount of time wait till it's over
and look at the final results it also
just went for a t-test but now we didn't
try on you would like to lose or dance
and stuff but most very test and avian
test dated the arm and it says England
for the first badge we just need it
really simple a/b test other thing did
is the actual test themselves just
configured them in code you thought of
having maybe a separate data store or
service or configuration file which
would have had some advantages but it
will also have added infrastructural
what's being so far this worked quite a
little crossed infinite kind of small
and easier to deploy so in the future
work we're looking to do with this maybe
testing framework is that in support of
a support area and APM testing we'd like
to try expanding to give you products
outside of pure search and also on the
servicing one thing we're really working
on is having more context specific great
models for search but kind of having
different models birth but when using
reverse the message communities are
different demands to know whether the
case you get a very large grid of gifts
people went continued explore the little
more of an exploratory context and then
like a pure messaging context or anyway
this is small scroll three initial gifts
in the viewport and that's really
relevant focus on exactly what they
start to work so they can set
- whoever they're talking to last thing
I'd like to say if we are hiring we're
making a big quest to really expand out
a lot for our search team our analytics
initiatives you get a port site
greenhouse done a little Skippy and
still help you job postings the higher a
data scientist data engineer to search
engineers and a product engineer the
report fairly closely with the search
team looking at a lot of the
infrastructure and analytics or inner
products yeah this was a thankful
the final one so in here where is the
feedback how does the feedback loop
between like a live searcher question
that down schematic yeah the choice
that's made me okay it's not super clear
but if you see in the blue that's urgent
micro-service that says the request
comes in it has a user idea we can flag
and toggle that experience and then in
are actually a t-test us tribution don't
just using the same stay in the shared
library for Hatchin 'yes 'ready between
the different experiences based on the
user ID and the time we can determine
with deterministic you know in a lot of
service when the request opinion it
downstream analytics they have the same
user ID so okay so everything that's in
blue is what the live comes back to the
user blue is all kind of all the live
service in the hops that go through when
interesting the live user request from
the browser or the clients of our
webinar he died or a certain point for
service Tom that those results get
delivered and the rest is more data
infrastructure for collecting his data
that was important I'm really curious
their enemy you're having a lot of
traffic a lot of requests no has
everything gone smoothly most part I
mean there are sometimes you know like
when an upstream client I'll put out
some chains it'll break some data
collection so there haven't been outages
and issues of those are the AP testing
it's not as big an issue it's like as
long as whatever change that may cause
data loss is the same effect that's not
bias by the controller the experiment
group and their data loss is evenly
distributed across the two groups it
doesn't impact the results of much but
there can be so weird like we didn't we
first rolled it out there's some weird
hashing both I can't rid of the exactly
so it's like really weird education I've
one of the I think experiment we get
heavily biased so so those should Scala
libraries are really important to get
right I mean it helps that they're
shared when we first rolled this out is
that actually before we have a certain
micro service and our APR 19 2014 4 2000
library work we had to totally make sure
they were in perfect sync and it worked
initially but once we had when goes
dedicated micro service you know it's
called it have this game
you